justin permettre pourquoi vous êtes
énervé contre mathieu à ce qu'ils
méritent ce qu'il a pris dans la gueule
comme wall-e pierre
géraud
sa d'insultés d'injures et pas oui j'ai
repris le modèle
a été insulté injurié menacé donc
excuses ne peut pas cautionner ça déjà à
la balance même pu placer une phrase
avant que l'ayatollah même coup
je vais vous dire ce que j'ai sur le
coeur les menaces mathieu je suis très
en colère contre vous parce que hier
vous avez tenu un discours de ce que
j'appelle de petits blancs qui sont
absents microcosme de privilégiés qui
voit pas la france telle qu'elle est
quand vous dites que les électeurs du
ray ne sont pas tous racistes et moi je
le dire en face de monsieur odoul vous
dites une monumentale bêtise ans les
électeurs du front national monsieur
votre parti est raciste votre quartier
est fondé sur les valeurs 11 lloris
rancennes oui millions
de français
sont racistes jci toilettes parce que
y'en a qui veulent répondre tout de
suite géraldine souhait c'est
insupportable en fait je pense qu'il n'y
a que deux personnes qui sont pas
racistes en france et gilles verdez
aiguillon j'en tombe franchement c'est
ce procès en hd c'est pas vous qui nous
méprisent et là nous irons descendants
sûre d'elle et non la dans la roue de
cyril hanouna qui m'a traitée tout à
l'heure d'ayatollahs ne sais pas quoi
jeter en soi qui pensent comme moi c'est
la mort
excuse moi mais on atteint 40 ans de
retard en fait mais tu diabolisent les
électeurs du front national j'ai volé
selon la la police d'abord le
rassemblement national
donc si tu dis que tu es là tu dois te
souviens quand même pas dire que tous
les gens qui votent pour marine le pen
ou pour zemmour d'ailleurs parce qu'il
est aussi d'extrême droite ils sont
racistes car c'est insupportable leur
idéologie raciste bidonvilles à
guillaume héras qui dit gilles un nom
mais que 7 millions
gironde et puis la raison les classes
populaires aujourd'hui elles votent pour
marine le pen elle va pas pour le
lévrier
ils votent pour marine le pen devance
josé les bonnes questions c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont racistes parce qu'on
les a déconsidéré les
apg découvrir
m'est arrivé c'est vrai la raison
qu'elles sont un peu
ya pas d paris dans l'avenir anne
hidalgo
paris il ya un éveil durbin embrasse je
rappelle je l'enverrai le titre de
douchka 1-2-3 jacques fait donald et
c'est paris je ne sais ni
l'extrême
alors il ya des règles pour ses missions
quand je parle c'est l'enfer non mais
vraiment pas que tout le monde connaît
des magouilles dont vous vous rendez
compte que vous insultez 11 millions de
francs c'était évidemment que dans le
programme de marine le pen il n'est pas
écrit noir sur blanc des propos racistes
pour la bonne et simple raison que c'est
interdit et condamnable en revanche
quand on regarde les propos de certains
membres du rassemblement national les
propos de certains électeurs du
rassemblement national je suis désolé
exor cet exemple ambages oui parce que
je sais qu'il me dire ça j'ai ouvert
j'ai tapé sa voix là j'allais vers le
premier article qui tombe antisémitisme
racisme islamophobie des candidats et
rennes toujours bas du fond donc il ya
eu c'est pas des exemples le sort mais
s'il y en a maintenant monsieur en
dérapage des lecteurs et c'est donc
force est de constater que c'est un
parti qui rassemble beaucoup de gens qui
sont racistes et moi je vous dire des
exemples que j'entends dans la vraie vie
tous les gens qui disent voilà je vote
marines et bah oui c'est vrai la raison
parce que franchement les noirs et des
arabes vraiment et c'est elle qui
rassemble des gens racistes est une
vérité et c'est démago de déchets vous
insultez des millions de français oui
d'accord oui je suis d'accord et
crémants finir ils sont pas tous
racistes oui mais c'est un parti qui
rassemble les gens racistes même dire la
vérité julie